I'm just a person with a passion who
really really believes that you know if
I have been given a life today then its
purpose is to be able to share as much
as I can with the world so that it
remains and it continues growing and
continues to give
Way Beyond my lifetime so that's who I
am I'm a people person I'm a people
person who lives and earns
to return welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Ronnie Perani the global CFO and
Executive Vice President of worldwide
all field machine and chairwoman of the
puranic foundation
Ronnie peronic is the co-owner Executive
Vice President and the CFO of
houston-based worldwide oil field
machine over 15 years ago she joined the
wom and oil and gas equipment
manufacturing firm and has since
implemented the framework for
communication standardization operations
and Business Development as a result of
these Frameworks the company grew to
more than 350 million dollars in annual
revenue and she has been named one of
the top 25 most influential women of
energy 2022 by oil and gas investor
Earnhardt energy
[Music]
all the way from Houston Texas Irani we
have a lot of things to cover
um you know quite a few different
subjects that
I I'm excited to see how they're gonna
you know flow together you have a few
hats your Executive Vice President and
Global CFO of worldwide oil field
machine Inc uh with more than belief
turnover of more than 250 million
dollars they are so I can't even imagine
what it's like being a CFO of an
organization like this so you're but
you're also really passionate about
mentorship and a part of The Chronic
Foundation as well and with an upcoming
book seven letters to my daughters which
is an awesome title and I'm excited to
uncover
um a little bit about your your life's
journey what you care about and
um and and pick your brand on all these
different subjects so so Ronnie you know
who are you how how does one get to deal
with all these uh different cool things
that you're doing oh my goodness who am
I I'm a person like you Michael
nobody different I'm just a person with
a passion who really really believes
that you know if I have been given a
life today then its purpose is to be
able to share as much as I can with the
world so that it remains and it
continues growing and continues to give
Way Beyond my lifetime so that's who I
am I'm a people person I'm a people
person who lives and earns
to return
that's really lame okay
so and what and what does that look like
because you have your your hands in in a
variety of different circumstances let's
start for example with with Worldwide
oil field machine what what do you what
is sort of how do you get into into this
field
um I know it's family related but how do
you get into this this whole situation
because that is not you know Global CFO
of such a large organization oild and
field and oil and gas and then you're
talking about also you know the
different mentorship stuff that you're
doing how do these things connect yeah
excellent question so for worldwide oil
to the machine
um I'll tell you something it's a 42
year old company
I was raised in this company but not my
entire life so let me give you a little
bit of my my life story just a quick
thing so the first 18 years of my life I
was basically raised here in Houston
Texas where my dad started this company
from nothing he was first generation
immigrant from India so started off with
a typical American Dream Story three
people in a garage I was three years old
I basically slept on the floor of our
pantry while Dad and Mom kind of you
know worked through this business and it
was really Mom bringing dinner and Dad
innovating
so watch that business grow this
business grow for the first 18 years of
my life I interned Summers were at the
office you know I knew everybody at the
office it was like an extended home for
me
the next 18 years of my life is when I
lived in Pune India and I was very very
young age I had an arranged marriage at
19 so you can imagine very young wow 19
19 exactly that's very that's very very
young a very young
um and by the time I had my first
daughter I was 21 and she started going
to school when she was 23. yeah what I
realized at that point is that I wanted
to be close to her so I started I
founded my own Dance Company
when my older daughter was three years
old and I'll tell you why dance is an in
is is a non-verbal form of expression
and communication and in a place like
India where girls really are usually
told what to do what to say what career
path to choose who would it marry right
like me
I could relate to these girls so so
deeply on a so deep level then I said
all right verbal communication might
feel a little disrespectful for the
culture but non-verbal communication and
if we could bring these girls together
where they could just Express be free
understand who they are in a very safe
environment then that was giving me joy
because it was empowering me at the same
time I was also very young at that time
I was only 24 when I started this
company so
I did this for about 15 years uh in Pune
India and again that had me discover my
passion for people
uh when I was 17 years old I took a
quick trip to India and even at that
time I had like a makeshift after school
program for slum kids and I renew I
really loved all of this until I
actually got into it so 14 years 18
years and living in India then that's
when I decided okay I've been preaching
to the world because that dance company
Michael it took off it literally took
off so
we were no I was not just teaching to
girls then it was to boys to juvenile
twins to
just just deaf children to uh University
started contacting me corporations
started to contact me Software
Corporations for team building and stuff
like that because it was about
speaking up and having the confidence to
understand acknowledge who I am as a
person and appreciating the differences
in everyone else around me and working
together which is the key to success
so after that happened I was preaching
to the world be who you are step up for
who you think you who you believe
yourself to be
I had to make a shift in my own life
and then I returned back to the United
States to Houston Texas my home City uh
in 2007 and that's the time when I
rejoined wlm because remember that was
family for me I had no other family here
so even though yes it's a business for
me it was like coming home to my
extended family and I knew it at that
time my girls were much younger and I
just could not start from scratch again
and another I was a young adult at that
time in a country where I had all these
responsibilities so WM was my go-to at
that time my dad asked so what do you
want to do said I really don't know what
would you like me to do he said I don't
know figure it out so they're trying to
figure it out basically meant that I
needed to go and talk to people because
I'm a Problem Solver I am what is called
your bridge I'm trying to help
facilitate people be their best selves
that's what I did in India my entire
life
so I started our HR department from
scratch we never had an HR department
even though we were like 20 200 250
people here in Houston at that time
so when talking to people I realize that
I need to self-train myself did
everything from assembly to uh process
routing to to Erp systems uh just the
whole stuff and then Financial
controllership looking into the admin
thing looking at the financial
structuring of things that's when I
decided to go back to school so when I
was 40 years old decided to go back to
Rice University got my MBA in five wow
yeah at 14. let me tell you everyone was
like you're 40.
why are you doing this how can you get
an MBA now you're too old and then the
other part which really I do not believe
in and people especially from like you
know they think that children from Bad
Business families should have some kind
of entitlement not me I needed to know
that I earned a position or I have
enough knowledge to really mean my best
and show up as my best so people would
ask me you know well you're the daughter
of the owner why do you need to work why
do you need to get an education well
because I do I need to show up for
myself
so graduated in 2014 then I took the
next two years to really travel the
world so right now we're in 11 locations
well actually at that time we were in
eight locations I opened up three uh
recently uh
and talk to everybody so out of the 4
000 people that work with Guam I never
say we work for anybody we work with and
together
uh I'll probably tell you I know 80 of
them I really do by name so we I don't
know them by numbers I know them by name
and really worked hand in hand with them
and all of a sudden people just started
to direct problems to me helping uh you
know to find Solutions together so I was
promoted to Global CFO in 2016
organically
it was a decision by the people not So
Much by a family or anything like that
it was literally made by people and well
we come to Ronnie anyways so that I
would tell you was pretty cool so that's
the passion for me the passion for me is
trying to keep this Legacy going it's a
great company with great people with a
great product
wow sounds really really cool and I and
I love the it sounds like um your path
with all the intentionality inside of it
you know has a lot of you you mentioned
giving back to before but it sounds like
the way that you're working is very
um you know it's it's a very
collaborative nature it's a lot of trust
based and and you're very tuned to to
those around you and how and they
impacted your mating and in receiving
giving
tell me about seven letters to my
daughters what is the motivation for the
book and what is it about uh yeah so in
the title seven letters uh the question
is what is seven so I really believe
there's a science that says that our
cells regenerate every seven years so
technically we are different people
every seven years so when I was about 49
years old my daughters you know we were
just kind of reminiscing on our life
journey and stuff like that in a really
good place they're like Mom we've really
come such a long way you should write a
book and you know because of my creative
background I've written scripts and
songs and all of that so they said you
should write a book and I said yeah okay
I guess I should
really became uh it was inspired by both
uh Sherry you and bhaktiague were my
daughters but it became a book that I
wanted to dedicate for not just all the
daughters of the world Michael but to
all the sons and when I say all the
people of the world because regardless
of gender and yes gender does play a
little bit of a part of the story of the
struggles
but every person has frustration every
person has challenges every person feels
like the lowest point of their lives
that has come at some point
to be able to overcome that to see the
positivity to be ambitious yet humble to
actually find a vision but still be
open-minded to know that you may have to
Pivot and change a little bit and adapt
all these lessons are things that I had
learned over the years but guess what
and seven year chunks so I say that for
the first seven years I was not a
daughter I was a girl in an Indian
family very different context and the
lessons that you learn from that
second seven years I was a sister
nothing else I have siblings when I
became seven years old so there was a
very clear pattern of my life
continuously changing after seven years
so I have one letter for every seven
years so therefore now I'm 50. the seven
letters to my daughters and really it's
about the lessons of love
and love in his purest form because even
in a multinational company organization
I lead by love and I know a lot of CEOs
don't talk about love because it's like
oh my God what are you talking about
but love in its purest form is power it
literally is power because it brings
empathy it allows you to listen it
allows you to understand what someone
else's passion will be and allows you to
let go and partner that passion for
other people as well so I lead through
love my lessons are about love about
leadership and about Legacy
and all of those lessons have made me
who I am today
that's awesome how does uh leading by
love
play a role within an organization like
you like to like yours a large
organization you know
how do you how do you lead by love well
what what is what are some examples of
that so I've been known to be an
empathetic leader not a sympathetic
leader empathy empathy is when as you
know you know as when I feel what
someone else is feeling and that's what
I say it's called love doubled up
so it's not just what you're feeling but
I'm feeling it with you
difference between sympathy and empathy
and when I am with somebody or somebody
is with me then as a leader knowing that
I may have a little bit more experience
than another person
it makes it so much easier for me to
relate at the same level and then to
lift to raise to then really bring out
and bring forward because at that point
then we're doing it together no person
is doing it on theirs by themselves that
teamwork is power and that teamwork
builds a great company great companies
are only made up of great people and
great people come from great teams
so empathy plays a big role in
everything that I do
I love it I love it so looking to
looking back to some of these lessons
that that you're sharing share with me
some more so you mentioned you mentioned
a few a few examples of them and I'm
curious to hear a little bit more about
those different things that you're that
as you're reflecting what what what main
lessons you decided are most crucial to
share with with the people that you love
most
well
um so it's interesting some people ask
me about you know like sister how do you
learn something about leadership uh
being a sister so as being an older
sister an older sister I had three
siblings at the time and you know you're
in this position where
for me at least I wanted to take all
this responsibility you know make sure
that they were well taken care of and of
course my parents were around but as the
oldest sibling you sort of do this on
your own
but the reality is I did not have
authority I have parents that would
swoop my siblings up away teach them
whatever they wanted to brainwash them
in a different way completely in an
operative Direction than me and that is
a lesson that I see every single time
even in large businesses small
businesses there is something called
middle management even sometimes at a
heart management where we take on
responsibility but not necessarily do we
have the authority so how do you
maneuver your teams siblings teams
groups of people
when you know that you don't have the
authority but you have to take the
responsibility and still move things
forward well how do you do that so
there's a very fine balance of how that
that can be led forward and a big Power
of that is to let go to know that you're
not the one with control you are not the
one in control and as a leader of the
company I understand how important it is
to also give Authority while people take
on responsibility otherwise I am not
giving them full Justice
so just as a teacher I learned so much
right and from my leader that I put into
my leadership skills so things like that
um being a mother I'll tell you
something is very of interest to me many
people call me the wam mom because
um you know we run schools uh not just
in India but we're very involved through
our foundation within the Greater
Houston area as well starting our own
Charter School
partnering up with countries like Brazil
hopefully Mexico so education is huge on
my mind so I deal with kids all the time
all the time I always have it since I
was 17 years old
so what does that mean when I come to
the company and
use my lessons as being a mother
being a mother
means that you're a parent which means
that
there's a time for a mother to care and
nurture and there's a time for a mother
just did that watch and let
her children or her people make mistakes
fumble because she knows with a little
bit of wisdom a little bit more
experience that those mistakes are just
going to strengthen them
are going to make them even better
and really form them for who they were
built to be
and that's how I lead a lot of the times
here in the company too like look make
mistakes if you're not making enough
mistakes you're not doing enough
so make them the important goal is to
not make the same mistake over and over
again then you're not learning
so there are a lot of lessons that I
have learned that I literally
incorporate every day into my world and
I have seen success come from it
very very cool what's your vision what's
your vision with what you do yeah my
vision for what I do Michael is this
like I mentioned earlier I completely
believe in the earn and return cycle
which means that I believe in Legacy I
lost my brother in 2018 he was only 38
years old he was part of the business
and at that time I really realized that
we all have an expiry date all of us no
matter what and there were so many lives
that came before me they did I'm not
sitting in the years of World War One in
two of the Cold War I'm not somehow
somebody some lives came before me that
have set the stage for me to live the
way I do which I'm going to assume is is
better it's easier so with that same
knowledge I also know I may have maybe
20 30 more years left not a lot left but
it's important to know that I can still
carve the path for all the lives that
are going to be coming after me
so whatever decision I make whether it's
in my family organization non-profit new
businesses whatever whatever decision I
make let it be so that someone else's
life after me
is easier better more successful and
stable stability is such an important
part of this so that's what drives me
every morning and the way I run the
businesses or teach my kids at school or
hang out with my kids my own kids and
the family
it's about Legacy it's about Thinking
Beyond yourself without depleting
yourself knowing that you are whole and
complete and therefore you can share
yourself bold and complete
that's incredible yeah I love the the
intentionality behind everything that
you're everything that you're managing
in here yeah it sounds a really uh it
sounds like you've really even just a
lot of thought and maybe it sounds like
you live your life in a way that lives
you very leaves you very fulfilled and
and passionate about the interactions
that you're having with others the
interactions you're having with yourself
and the way that you're viewing and
sharing this journey with other people
and so definitely a conversation that's
much greater than just uh your your your
work with with woman with the mentorship
and and the product Foundation it's
really about sort of a life saying
Mantra Legacy and so I really want to
thank you Ronnie for taking this time to
share it with me it was a wonderful
conversation and best of luck with
fulfilling your vision and thank you
again for being here thank you Michael I
always say that there's always a way to
be playful powerful and purposeful
easy